Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. If any bastard ever thought about going to the cops about us, they'll be killed. And so will their fucking families. And if we don't get them, our mates will. It would be a shame if anything happened to your sweet little pru, wouldn't it? Those words were allegedly said by one of the men convicted for the Russell Street bombing. The person he said those words to? Paul Hetzel. Hetzel was the man arrested, turned crown witness and whose evidence was instrumental in the conviction of the Russell Street bombers. Pru Birds case is related to the Russell Street case. So if you haven't yet listened to those two episodes, I suggest you do so before listening to this one.
你试过在烧烤上再加烧烤吗？想象一下：新鲜烹制的酥脆调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉，再淋上奶油烧烤酱。想象不出来？那你现在可以在Tim's尝试一下。限时供应我们全新的BBQ脆皮鸡肉碗和卷饼。如果有人敢想去警察那里告发我们，他们就会被杀掉。他们的家人也一样。如果我们没能除掉他们，我们的同伙也会动手。如果你的宝贝小普鲁出了什么事，那可真是太遗憾了，不是吗？这些话据称是罗素街爆炸案的定罪者之一说的。他对着谁说的？保罗·赫策尔。赫策尔是被捕后转为污点证人的人，他的证词对罗素街爆炸案凶手的定罪起到了关键作用。普鲁·伯德的案件与罗素街案件有关。所以，如果你还没听过那两集，我建议你在听这一集之前先去听听。
Although it's a totally separate investigation, it's kind of a Russell Street part three. Pru Bird was 13 years old and the oldest of three children. She lived with her mother Jenny Bird on Justin Avenue in Glenroy, Victoria. Glenroy is just outside of the Melbourne City area, about 13 kilometres, 8 miles. Pru's father died when she was only one and her mother Jenny remarried and had two other children to her new husband, Benny Bird. Benny adopted Pru and became a father figure to her. Jenny eventually separated from Benny and she was now in a relationship with a woman, Isabelle. Pru hated the fact that Jenny and Benny had split up and Isabelle had moved in. It was causing friction in the household. Pru resented Isabelle. In the summer of 1992, Pru and her friend Sarah, which isn't her real name, were at Pru's house. A man knocked on the door who Pru didn't recognise. The man said, is that Daniel's car?
虽然这是一个完全独立的调查，但它算是罗素街案件的第三部分。普鲁·伯德当时13岁，是三个孩子中的老大。她和母亲珍妮·伯德住在维多利亚州格伦罗伊的贾斯汀大道。格伦罗伊就在墨尔本市区外，大约13公里，即8英里远。普鲁的父亲在她一岁时就去世了，母亲珍妮再婚，并与新丈夫本尼·伯德生了两个孩子。本尼收养了普鲁，成为了她的父亲形象。珍妮最终与本尼分居，现在正与一名叫伊莎贝尔的女性交往。普鲁很讨厌珍妮和本尼分手、伊莎贝尔搬进来的事实。这导致了家庭内部的摩擦。普鲁很反感伊莎贝尔。1992年夏天，普鲁和她的朋友莎拉（化名）在普鲁家。一个普鲁不认识的男人敲了门。那个男人问：“那是丹尼尔的车吗？”
Pru had no idea who Daniel was or what this man was talking about. She replied, no. The man said, are you sure? Pru didn't know what was going on. She said yes and then slammed the door in his face. Sarah didn't go to the door so she didn't see the man, but Pru was really shaken up and had turned pale because she said the man was really weird. Sarah left Pru's house a few hours later. As she was walking down Pru's street, a man drove past her in a blue car and waved. Sarah didn't recognise him or the car so she kept walking. The man turned the car around and started driving slowly at walking pace next to Sarah. He was smiling and waving and didn't take his eyes off her. Sarah was freaked out and started running. She ran to a nearby friend's house. The man in the blue car took off. Sarah called Pru and asked her to describe the man who had earlier knocked on her door asking about Daniel's car. Between them they worked out that the man who knocked on the door and the man who stalked Sarah in the car were the same person.
普鲁根本不知道丹尼尔是谁，也不知道这个男人在说什么。她回答说：“不是。”男人问：“你确定吗？”普鲁不知道发生了什么事。她说“确定”，然后就把门关上了。莎拉没去门口，所以没看到那个男人，但普鲁被吓坏了，脸色苍白，因为她说那个男人真的很奇怪。几小时后，莎拉离开了普鲁家。当她走在普鲁住的那条街上时，一个男人开着一辆蓝色轿车经过她身边并挥了挥手。莎拉不认识他也不认识那辆车，所以继续走。那个男人把车掉头，开始以步行速度在莎拉旁边缓慢行驶。他微笑着挥手，眼睛一直盯着她。莎拉吓坏了，开始奔跑。她跑到了附近一个朋友家。那辆蓝色轿车的男人开走了。莎拉打电话给普鲁，让她描述一下之前敲门问丹尼尔车子的那个男人。她们两人确认，敲门的男人和在车里跟踪莎拉的男人是同一个人。
Not long after that incident, on the 2nd of February 1992, Jenny Byrd, Pru's mum, left the house early in the morning. Pru was still asleep and what she didn't know was that Jenny had arranged for Isabel to move out that day, not to end their relationship, but just to make things less intrusive for Pru. Jenny returned home about 1pm. Pru was actually still in better sleep. Isabel was waiting for friends to turn up to help her move. In the meantime, Jenny asked if she could drive her down to the local pool so she could go for a swim on what was a very hot summer's day. Isabel agreed and she was gone for only about 20 minutes. When she arrived home, her two friends had arrived to help her move. While they were having a cup of coffee before they got to work, Pru woke up and walked out of her room. She said hello to Isabel and her friends, emptied a tin of cream corn onto a plate, put it in the microwave and then walked back to her room. About 1.45pm the phone rang. Isabel answered. It was a teenage boy asking for Pru.
那次事件后不久，1992年2月2日，普鲁的妈妈珍妮·伯德一大早就离开了家。普鲁还在睡觉，她不知道珍妮已经安排伊莎贝尔那天搬出去，不是为了结束她们的关系，只是为了让普鲁的生活少受些干扰。珍妮下午1点左右回到家。普鲁其实还在睡觉。伊莎贝尔正在等朋友来帮忙搬家。与此同时，珍妮问伊莎贝尔能不能开车送她去当地的游泳池，好让她在这个炎热的夏日去游个泳。伊莎贝尔同意了，她只离开了大约20分钟。当她回到家时，她的两个朋友已经到了，准备帮她搬家。当他们在干活前喝咖啡时，普鲁醒了，走出房间。她和伊莎贝尔及她的朋友们打了招呼，把一罐奶油玉米倒在盘子里，放进微波炉，然后回到了自己的房间。下午1点45分左右，电话响了。伊莎贝尔接了电话。是一个十几岁的男孩找普鲁。
Pru did take the call but Isabel didn't hear the conversation because she walked out and started lighting up the trailer for her move. 30 minutes later the phone rang again. Isabel was still busy out in the garage. She assumes Pru answered the call although she isn't sure. About 2.30pm, 15 minutes after that second phone call, Isabel had finished packing the trailer and her friends left the house driving off with the stuff. Isabel had a few things to finish up inside. As she made her way inside she noticed the front door was wide open, the television was on, the plate of cream corn was sitting on the coffee table in the lounge room untouched and Pru was gone. Jenny Bird arrived home sometime after 6pm that night. She saw the cream corn on the coffee table that was still untouched. There was no sign of Pru at all. If Pru was going somewhere she would always leave a note. But there wasn't one. Still Jenny assumed Pru would be at a friends house or with a relative and she started calling around but no one had seen or heard from her. By 9.30pm Jenny was in a panic and she called the police. The first time she called she was told teenagers go missing all the time and usually turn up soon after. That was all the help she got. The only thing missing was Pru's school bag and a pair of pants. Pru's school books had been emptied out of her bag and were still at home. The rest of Pru's clothes and belongings were left untouched. No money had been taken.
普鲁确实接了电话，但伊莎贝尔没听到谈话内容，因为她走出去开始装载搬家用的拖车。30分钟后，电话又响了。伊莎贝尔还在车库里忙碌。她推测是普鲁接的电话，尽管她不确定。下午2点30分左右，也就是第二次电话响过15分钟后，伊莎贝尔装好了拖车，她的朋友们开车带着东西离开了。伊莎贝尔还有些事情要在屋里处理。当她走进屋时，她注意到前门大开，电视开着，客厅咖啡桌上的那盘奶油玉米没动过，而普鲁不见了。珍妮·伯德那天晚上6点多回到家。她看到了咖啡桌上那盘没动过的奶油玉米。普鲁完全不见踪影。如果普鲁要出门，她总是会留张字条。但这次没有。珍妮仍然以为普鲁是在朋友家或亲戚家，于是开始四处打电话，但没人见过或听说过她。晚上9点30分，珍妮陷入恐慌，报了警。她第一次报警时，被告知青少年经常失踪，通常很快就会出现。这就是她得到的全部帮助。唯一不见的东西是普鲁的书包和一条裤子。普鲁的课本被从书包里倒了出来，还在家里。普鲁的其他衣服和物品都没动过。没有钱被拿走。
And the cream corn was the most alarming thing. Pru never went anywhere before she ate. Jenny didn't believe for a second that Pru had run away. She called the police again. After this second call police turned up and took a report. Jenny Byrd was the eldest of four children and grew up in a flat in West Brunswick, Victoria. A suburb just outside of the Melbourne city area. Her mother Julie had a very bad temper and was capable of extreme violence. There were a lot of fights between Julie and Jenny's father Jim and that in turn would be taken out on the kids. The household generally wasn't a very pleasant place to live. Jenny planned to move out as soon as she could. She was gone when she was 17. She moved in with her boyfriend Terry, Pru's father. But Terry was tragically killed in a car accident. Later Jenny met and married Benny Byrd whom she had two other children with and Benny also adopted Pru. It was around this time that Julie split up with Jenny's father Jim. Julie hooked up with another man who was soon sent to jail for a shooting. Julie was attracted to violent men and she didn't let the prison sentence stop her from seeing her new boyfriend.
最令人不安的是那盘奶油玉米。普鲁从不吃东西前就出门。珍妮一秒钟都不相信普鲁是离家出走了。她再次报警。第二次报警后，警察赶到并做了笔录。珍妮·伯德是四个孩子中的老大，在维多利亚州西不伦瑞克的一间公寓里长大。那是墨尔本市区外的一个郊区。她的母亲朱莉脾气非常暴躁，有极强的暴力倾向。朱莉和珍妮的父亲吉姆之间经常打架，这反过来又会发泄在孩子们身上。那个家庭通常不是一个宜居的地方。珍妮计划一有机会就搬出去。她17岁时就离开了。她和男友特里（普鲁的父亲）住在一起。但特里不幸在车祸中丧生。后来珍妮遇到了本尼·伯德并结婚，他们又生了两个孩子，本尼也收养了普鲁。大约就在这个时候，朱莉和珍妮的父亲吉姆分开了。朱莉又找了另一个男人，那个人很快因枪击案被送进监狱。朱莉被暴力男性吸引，她并没有让监狱判决阻止她与新男友见面。
But it was while visiting him in jail that Julie met and fell in love with another inmate, Paul Hetzel. Julie became infatuated with Paul who was serving a 22 year jail sentence for armed robbery and the attempted murder of a police officer. You will recall from the Russell Street episodes that it was while serving Miss Jail term that Paul also became best friends with Stan Taylor. One of the men convicted of the Russell Street bombing. Paul Hetzel was released from jail in 1981 and Julie was waiting for him. The two were madly in love and got married soon after. Paul and Julie Hetzel. Jenny Byrd was now Paul's stepdaughter. Her daughter Pru Byrd was now Paul's step-granddaughter. Julie wasn't the only person waiting for Paul Hetzel when he was released from jail. His good mate Stan Taylor who got released before Paul was also waiting. And it wasn't long before Paul was a part of Stan's crew committing a string of violent armed robberies starting with smaller country hotels before progressing up to banks around Melbourne.
但正是在探监时，朱莉遇到了另一名囚犯保罗·赫策尔并坠入爱河。朱莉迷上了保罗，他因武装抢劫和谋杀警察未遂正在服22年刑期。你可能还记得罗素街案件中提到，保罗在服刑期间与斯坦·泰勒成为了最好的朋友。斯坦·泰勒是罗素街爆炸案的定罪者之一。保罗·赫策尔于1981年出狱，朱莉一直在等他。两人疯狂相爱，不久后结婚。保罗和朱莉·赫策尔。珍妮·伯德现在是保罗的继女。她的女儿普鲁·伯德现在是保罗的继孙女。朱莉并不是保罗·赫策尔出狱时唯一等待他的人。他的好朋友斯坦·泰勒在保罗之前出狱，也在等他。没过多久，保罗就成了斯坦团伙的一员，开始了一系列暴力武装抢劫，从小型乡村旅馆开始，然后升级到墨尔本各地的银行。
The robberies were vicious, a number of people were badly beaten, smashed over the head with guns and kicked while they were on the floor. Their aim was to instill as much fear into people as possible so they would do whatever they wanted. The other people in Stan's crew you will remember were Craig Minogue, his brother Rodney Minogue and Peter Reed. The other men arrested for the Russell Street bombing. Jenny Byrd obviously knew her stepfather Paul Hetzel had a criminal past. Her mother had met him in jail. And she never really liked him. She says she was actually scared of him. Pru on the other hand absolutely loved Julie and Paul, grandma and grandpa. She always wanted to visit and would spend weeks at a time with them. Jenny was comfortable with this, she felt it was important that Pru had a healthy relationship with her grandparents and thought she would be safe with them. Of course that meant Pru was in regular contact with Paul's close mates, Stan Taylor, Craig and Rodney Minogue and Peter Reed. They met Pru countless times. She was always visiting. Paul never saw a problem with this, he believed in the criminal code. No matter what, you never hurt women or children. This code is what Paul believed would keep Pru safe.
抢劫非常残忍，许多人被毒打，头部被枪托重击，倒地后还被踢踹。他们的目的是尽可能地在人们心中灌输恐惧，这样人们就会对他们言听计从。你可能还记得斯坦团伙里的其他人是克雷格·米诺格、他的兄弟罗德尼·米诺格和彼得·里德。他们是罗素街爆炸案中被捕的其他几个人。珍妮·伯德显然知道她的继父保罗·赫策尔有犯罪前科。她母亲是在监狱里认识他的。她从来都不喜欢他。她说她其实很怕他。另一方面，普鲁非常爱朱莉和保罗，也就是她的祖父母。她总是想去探望他们，并会和他们住上几周。珍妮对此感到放心，她觉得普鲁与祖父母保持健康的关系很重要，并认为普鲁和他们在一起是安全的。当然，这意味着普鲁经常接触保罗的亲密伙伴：斯坦·泰勒、克雷格和罗德尼·米诺格以及彼得·里德。他们无数次见过普鲁。她总是去探望。保罗从不觉得这有什么问题，他相信犯罪准则。无论如何，绝不伤害妇女或儿童。保罗相信这条准则能保护普鲁的安全。
Paul says Stan Taylor had been talking about blowing up Russell Street since he was in jail. Paul believed it was just Stan talking shit, jailhouse tough talk. A criminal who hates cops, nothing shocking about that. Paul said he was always of the belief that Stan would never go through with it. On Thursday the 27th of March 1986, when the bomb went off in Russell Street, Paul and Julie heard the news over the radio. They looked at each other and knew straight away who was involved. The day after the bombing, Stan Taylor bragged to Paul, telling him all about it, fully implicating himself. At least that's Paul Hetzel's story. Paul was a violent career criminal who was described as very cunning. He knew the system, knew exactly how to play it and was only ever interested in looking out for himself. There are those that believe Paul had a far greater role in the bombing than what he makes out. To the point where some police who were guarding him while he was under witness protection had a tough time, as they felt he was just as responsible as the men who were charged with the bombing. Remember too, he had already served a lengthy sentence for armed robbery and for the attempted murder of a police officer. And after the bombing, Paul and Julie Hetzel were actually living with Stan Taylor at Berchit. That's the small country town outside of Melbourne, where Craig and Rodney Minogue were also living. The night before Stan and the Minogue brothers were arrested the 29th of May 1986, is the night that Paul and Julie Hetzel, say Craig Minogue, made that chilling threat about their granddaughter, Prude.
保罗说斯坦·泰勒从在监狱里时就一直在谈论炸掉罗素街。保罗认为那只是斯坦在吹牛，是监狱里的狠话。一个仇视警察的罪犯，这没什么好奇怪的。保罗说他一直认为斯坦永远不会付诸行动。1986年3月27日星期四，当罗素街发生爆炸时，保罗和朱莉在收音机里听到了新闻。他们对视一眼，立刻就知道是谁干的。爆炸发生后的第二天，斯坦·泰勒向保罗吹嘘，告诉了他所有细节，完全牵连了自己。至少这是保罗·赫策尔的说法。保罗是一个暴力职业罪犯，被描述为非常狡猾。他了解体制，知道如何利用它，并且只关心自己的利益。有些人认为保罗在爆炸案中扮演的角色远比他所说的要大。甚至一些在他接受证人保护期间负责看守他的警察也感到很头疼，因为他们觉得他与那些被指控爆炸案的人一样负有责任。还要记住，他之前因武装抢劫和谋杀警察未遂已经服了很长的刑期。爆炸案发生后，保罗和朱莉·赫策尔实际上和斯坦·泰勒住在伯奇特。那是墨尔本郊外的一个小乡村城镇，克雷格和罗德尼·米诺格也住在那里。在斯坦和米诺格兄弟被捕的前一天晚上，即1986年5月29日，保罗和朱莉·赫策尔说，克雷格·米诺格发出了那个关于他们孙女普鲁的令人不寒而栗的威胁。
If any bastard ever thought about going to the cops about us, they'll be killed. And so will their fucking families. And if we don't get them, our mates will. It would be a shame if anything happened to your sweet little Prude, wouldn't it? Prude was asleep in the next room when this threat was made. Now Craig Minogue strongly denies ever making this threat and claims that Hetzel's made it up. The next day, Stan Taylor and the Minogue brothers were arrested for the Russell Street bombing. Paul and Julie Hetzel were also arrested, although Julie was released soon after without charge. The police had enough evidence on Paul Hetzel to implicate him in the string of armed robberies the group had committed. And they also suspected he may have had some involvement in Russell Street as well. For Paul, it was very simple. Shut up and say nothing and get charged with the bombing and the murder of Constable Angela Taylor, or tell the police what he knew. Paul was well aware he would never see the light of day again if he was convicted for Russell Street. So Paul decided to talk. He told the police everything. His evidence was described as the jewel in the prosecution's case. He denied any direct involvement in the bombing himself. And the police say they couldn't prove otherwise. If they could actually put him at the scene or prove he was directly involved, he would have been charged as well.
“如果任何混蛋想去警察那里告发我们，他们就会被杀掉。他们的家人也一样。如果我们没能除掉他们，我们的同伙也会动手。如果你的宝贝小普鲁出了什么事，那可真是太遗憾了，不是吗？”当这个威胁发出时，普鲁正在隔壁房间睡觉。现在，克雷格·米诺格强烈否认曾发出过这种威胁，并声称是赫策尔夫妇编造的。第二天，斯坦·泰勒和米诺格兄弟因罗素街爆炸案被捕。保罗和朱莉·赫策尔也被捕，尽管朱莉不久后被无罪释放。警方掌握了足够的证据，将保罗·赫策尔牵连进该团伙犯下的一系列武装抢劫案中。他们还怀疑他可能也参与了罗素街爆炸案。对保罗来说，这很简单：闭嘴什么都不说，然后被指控爆炸案和谋杀安吉拉·泰勒警官，或者告诉警察他所知道的一切。保罗很清楚，如果他因罗素街案件被定罪，他将永无天日。所以保罗决定开口。他告诉了警察一切。他的证词被描述为检方案件中的“宝石”。他否认自己直接参与了爆炸案。警方表示他们无法证明事实并非如此。如果他们能证明他在现场或直接参与，他也会被起诉。
But they couldn't prove it. Needless to say, Paul's cooperation made Stan Taylor and Craig Minogue very, very angry. They were convicted in 1988 and both received life sentences. Rodney Minogue was acquitted for being an accessory, but still served some time for the armed robberies. Peter Ried was found not guilty of Russell Street, but served nine years for the armed robberies and he shoot out with police when he was arrested. Paul and Julie were put into witness protection. They had to change their names and cut themselves off from everybody, unable to let anyone know where they were. Jenny Bird was also told to change her name and move to a safe house. Jenny lived under a clout, fearful for her and her children's safety. And it was four years after the conviction of the Russell Street bombers on the 2nd of February 1992, when those fears became a reality. Pru was missing. Jenny Bird was frustrated with police efforts to investigate Pru's disappearance, or their lack of effort.
但他们无法证明。不用说，保罗的合作让斯坦·泰勒和克雷格·米诺格非常、非常愤怒。他们于1988年被定罪，两人都被判处终身监禁。罗德尼·米诺格因从犯身份被判无罪，但仍因武装抢劫服了一段时间刑。彼得·里德被判罗素街案件无罪，但因武装抢劫和被捕时与警察的枪战服刑了九年。保罗和朱莉被纳入证人保护计划。他们不得不改名换姓，与所有人断绝联系，不能让任何人知道他们在哪里。珍妮·伯德也被告知要改名并搬到安全屋。珍妮生活在恐惧中，担心她和孩子们的安全。在罗素街爆炸案凶手被定罪四年后，即1992年2月2日，这些恐惧变成了现实。普鲁失踪了。珍妮·伯德对警方调查普鲁失踪案的努力，或者说他们的不作为感到沮丧。
Jenny knew Pru hadn't run away. Her family knew that she hadn't run away. But the police initially insisted that was most likely the case. It wasn't until many weeks later they started to take a bit more interest when they realized the significance of who Pru was, or who her grandparents were. At the time of Pru's disappearance, Paul and Julie Hetzel were living on the other side of the country, in Western Australia. When Jenny rang them to tell the news, she says Paul Hetzel was strangely aggressive, rather than sympathetic. His words were, what the hell do you expect us to do all the way over here? Given how much they said they loved and adored Pru, Jenny assumed they both would have been on a plane that night to get to Melbourne. But they weren't. It took them a week to make that trip, and when they did arrive, there were no tears, no sympathy. Jenny says Paul was acting extremely odd. His first words to her when he arrived were, what the fuck are you crying for?
珍妮知道普鲁没有离家出走。她的家人都知道她没有离家出走。但警方最初坚持认为这最有可能。直到几周后，当他们意识到普鲁是谁，或者她的祖父母是谁的重要性时，他们才开始表现出一点兴趣。普鲁失踪时，保罗和朱莉·赫策尔住在全国的另一端，西澳大利亚州。当珍妮打电话告诉他们这个消息时，她说保罗·赫策尔表现得异常咄咄逼人，而不是同情。他的话是：“你到底指望我们在这么远的地方做什么？”鉴于他们说他们有多爱和宠爱普鲁，珍妮以为他们那天晚上就会坐飞机赶到墨尔本。但他们没有。他们花了一周时间才赶过来，当他们到达时，没有眼泪，没有同情。珍妮说保罗表现得非常奇怪。他到达时对她说的第一句话是：“你他妈哭什么？”
Another pretty disturbing comment he made to the panic-stricken Jenny, whose 13-year-old daughter had been missing for over a week, was, she's probably out getting the ass fucked off her. Of course, that's what Jenny alleges Paul said, and Paul denies it. So make of it what you will. Paul and Julie insisted that Pru had just run away. Jenny was taken aback by their behaviour and lack of concern. When the runaway theory didn't quite add up, Paul and Julie started to try and shift the blame onto Isabelle, Jenny's partner, insisting she must be somehow involved. The police did thoroughly investigate Isabelle out of necessity. She was the last person to see Pru, but she was cleared. There is no way she had anything to do with it. Years later, Jenny and Paul said that they insisted on these alternate theories because it was easier to believe than their revenge theory. If it was revenge for Paul giving evidence, then that would mean they were responsible, and if they didn't want that on their conscience. After seven weeks, the case made its way onto the desk of Officer Chris Jones from the missing persons unit. The giant elephant in the room could no longer be ignored.
他对惊慌失措的珍妮说的另一句令人不安的话是——当时她13岁的女儿已经失踪了一周多——“她可能在外面被人搞呢。”当然，这是珍妮声称保罗说的话，而保罗否认了。所以你怎么想就怎么想吧。保罗和朱莉坚持认为普鲁只是离家出走了。珍妮对他们的行为和缺乏关心感到震惊。当离家出走理论站不住脚时，保罗和朱莉开始试图将责任推给珍妮的伴侣伊莎贝尔，坚持认为她一定以某种方式参与其中。警方确实出于必要彻底调查了伊莎贝尔。她是最后一个见到普鲁的人，但她被排除了嫌疑。她绝不可能与此事有关。多年后，珍妮和保罗说，他们坚持这些替代理论是因为这比他们的复仇理论更容易让人相信。如果是为了报复保罗提供证词，那就意味着他们要负责，而他们不想让这种良心债压在身上。七周后，案件摆到了失踪人口部门克里斯·琼斯警官的桌上。房间里那个巨大的大象再也无法被忽视了。
The Hetzels were crown witnesses under witness protection. The people Paul Hetzel testified against had allegedly made a threat that Pru would be harmed if they ever spoke to the police. Six years after that threat was made, and four years after their conviction, Pru was now missing. Chris Jones tried to get the Homicide Squad to take over the investigation, stating that the missing persons unit simply didn't have the resources required to thoroughly investigate. That request was denied. The head of the Homicide Squad telling Chris to keep looking at it and to let him know if he found anything. Chris never did find anything. Weeks turned into months, which turned into years. The case went totally cold, despite what seemed to be an obvious connection to Russell Street. Pru's case remained with the missing persons unit, just another name amongst the thousands of other missing people. Jenny tried to do her own investigating. She put up posters, talked to people in the street, tried to get media coverage of the case. But little was achieved until 2008. 16 years after Pru's disappearance. Jenny Byrd managed to convince the government to offer a $500,000 reward for any information that could help solve Pru's case.
赫策尔夫妇是受证人保护的皇家证人。保罗·赫策尔指控的人据称曾威胁说，如果他们敢向警方告密，普鲁就会受到伤害。在那个威胁发出六年之后，在他们被定罪四年之后，普鲁现在失踪了。克里斯·琼斯试图让凶杀组接手调查，称失踪人口部门根本没有彻底调查所需的资源。该请求被拒绝。凶杀组负责人告诉克里斯继续关注，如果发现什么就通知他。克里斯从未发现任何东西。几周变成了几个月，又变成了几年。尽管与罗素街案件有着明显的联系，但案件完全陷入了僵局。普鲁的案件留在了失踪人口部门，只是成千上万名失踪者中的另一个名字。珍妮试图自己调查。她张贴海报，与街上的人交谈，试图让媒体报道此案。但直到2008年，也就是普鲁失踪16年后，才取得了一点进展。珍妮·伯德成功说服政府为任何能帮助破获普鲁案件的信息提供50万澳元的悬赏。
It was after this reward was offered that the name Leslie Camilleri popped up. Camilleri was in jail, serving a life sentence without the possibility for parole. He had been convicted for committing the murders of 14-year-old Lauren Barry and 16-year-old Nicole Collins. Another well-known Australian case, otherwise known as the Bigger Schoolgirl Murders, which happened in 1997. Five years after Pru's disappearance. When Pru's case and the new reward started making headlines again in 2008, Camilleri confessed to the murder, freely admitting to police that he was the one who killed Pru Byrd. His version was that he approached Pru in the street because he believed Pru's father had sexually abused him when he was younger. Pru refused to tell him anything about her father, so he placed his hands around her neck until she was unconscious. He then hugged tied her and put her in his car, planning to ask her further questions about her father. But it was some time after that Camilleri realized Pru was dead.
正是在悬赏发出后，莱斯利·卡米莱里的名字出现了。卡米莱里当时正在监狱服刑，被判终身监禁且不得假释。他因谋杀14岁的劳伦·巴里和16岁的妮可·柯林斯而被定罪。这是另一个著名的澳大利亚案件，也就是1997年发生的“比格女学生谋杀案”，发生在普鲁失踪五年后。当普鲁的案件和新的悬赏在2008年再次成为头条新闻时，卡米莱里承认了谋杀罪，并向警方坦白他就是杀害普鲁·伯德的人。他的版本是他因为认为普鲁的父亲在他年轻时对他进行过性虐待，所以他在街上接近了普鲁。普鲁拒绝告诉他任何关于她父亲的事，所以他用手掐住她的脖子直到她失去知觉。然后他把她捆起来放进车里，计划问她更多关于她父亲的问题。但过了一段时间，卡米莱里意识到普鲁已经死了。
Camilleri was already never getting out of prison, and he wouldn't be the first person to admit to a murder he didn't commit. So police needed more than just his word for it. His story really wasn't adding up either. Pru's schoolbag had been emptied and was missing from the house, along with a pair of pants. And she left a plate of cream corn untouched on the table, something she would never do. She always ate before she left the house. Why would she empty her schoolbag, take a pair of pants, to just walk along the street? Where she just so happened to cross paths with Camilleri, who started asking her questions about her father who allegedly abused him when he was younger. No one believed Camilleri's version. It just didn't make sense. But that didn't mean he wasn't responsible. He was in jail for the violent murder of two girls around Pru's age. He was certainly capable. But his version seemed to be very self-serving, taking the blame, but trying to minimize it by saying it was just an accident, and he didn't mean to kill her.
卡米莱里本来就永远出不了监狱，他也不是第一个承认自己没犯过的谋杀案的人。所以警方需要的不仅仅是他的话。他的故事也确实说不通。普鲁的书包被倒空了，和一条裤子一起从家里消失了。而且她还在桌上留下了一盘没动过的奶油玉米，这是她绝不会做的事。她总是出门前先吃东西。她为什么要倒空书包，拿一条裤子，然后就那么走在街上？结果恰好遇到了卡米莱里，而卡米莱里开始问她关于她父亲的问题，说她父亲在他年轻时虐待过他。没人相信卡米莱里的版本。这根本说不通。但这并不意味着他没有责任。他因暴力谋杀两名与普鲁年龄相仿的女孩而入狱。他当然有能力。但他的版本似乎非常自私，他承担了责任，但试图通过说这只是个意外来将其最小化，并声称他没想杀她。
He just wanted to ask her further questions, and she died on him. After a thorough investigation, police believed he was actually involved, but he was coming up with a bullshit story to take the full rap, so nobody else would be implicated. The police strongly believed Camilleri didn't act alone. Pru's friend Sarah became a crucial witness. She says Camilleri was the man who followed her in the car that day she left Pru's house. The same man who knocked on Pru's door asking about Daniel's car. Although it was many years later that she made this identification by seeing Camilleri's picture in the paper. Another witness came forward which confirmed the belief that Camilleri wasn't acting alone. One of Pru's neighbours, Sam, not her real name.
他只是想问她更多问题，结果她死在他手里了。经过彻底调查，警方认为他确实参与其中，但他编造了一个胡扯的故事来承担全部罪责，这样就不会有其他人被牵连。警方强烈认为卡米莱里不是单独行动。普鲁的朋友莎拉成为了关键证人。她说卡米莱里就是那天她离开普鲁家时开车跟踪她的男人。也就是那个敲普鲁门问丹尼尔车子的男人。尽管她是多年后通过在报纸上看到卡米莱里的照片才做出这一辨认的。另一名证人站了出来，证实了卡米莱里并非单独行动的看法。普鲁的一位邻居，萨姆（化名）。
She came forward saying, the day Pru disappeared, she saw two cars parked near Pru's house. One of the cars was blue and similar in description to the car that followed Sarah during the incident before Pru's disappearance. Two men were standing outside the blue car smoking, and a third man was sitting in the second car watching. Later that day, Sam says she saw Pru in the back seat of the blue car. Pru was banging on the back window. Sam thought she was waving at first, but clearly she wasn't. Sam kept that information to herself for 16 years. The reason she says she never came forward was because she had no self-confidence. And she did eventually decide to come forward because she says she felt Pru's presence, and Pru was telling her to do something.
她站出来说，普鲁失踪那天，她看到两辆车停在普鲁家附近。其中一辆车是蓝色的，描述与普鲁失踪前跟踪莎拉的那辆车相似。两个男人站在蓝色车外抽烟，第三个男人坐在第二辆车里观察。那天晚些时候，萨姆说她看到普鲁坐在蓝色车的后座。普鲁在拍打后窗。萨姆起初以为她在挥手，但显然不是。萨姆把这个信息藏在心里16年。她说她从未站出来的原因是她没有自信。她最终决定站出来是因为她说她感受到了普鲁的存在，普鲁在告诉她要做点什么。
Camilleri wasn't from Victoria, he was from Yass, a country town in New South Wales. But he had a very close friend who he regularly visited in Victoria, Mark McConville. A well-connected, violent drug dealer, who just so happened to have links to the Russell Street bombing crew as well. He also owned a small blue car at the time of Pru's disappearance. So this is how it all ties together. It is alleged that Pru was abducted in a planned kidnapping as payback against Paul and Julie Hetzel for testifying in the Russell Street case. The bombers making good on their threat to harm Pru. Mark McConville, the violent associate of the bombers, and his good friend, child murderer Leslie Camilleri, were used to carry out the kidnapping and murder of Pru.
卡米莱里不是维多利亚州人，他来自新南威尔士州的乡村小镇亚斯。但他有一个经常在维多利亚州探望的密友，马克·麦康维尔。一个关系广泛、暴力成性的毒贩，恰好也与罗素街爆炸案团伙有联系。他在普鲁失踪时也拥有一辆蓝色小车。所以这就是这一切如何联系在一起的。据称，普鲁是被绑架的，这是一场有预谋的绑架，是为了报复保罗和朱莉·赫策尔在罗素街案件中作证。爆炸案凶手兑现了他们伤害普鲁的威胁。马克·麦康维尔，爆炸案凶手的暴力同伙，以及他的好朋友、杀童犯莱斯利·卡米莱里，被用来执行对普鲁的绑架和谋杀。
In another twist, Jenny Bird claims she saw Rodney Minogue in her street only a week before Pru disappeared. Not only that, she says some family members of Pru's boyfriend at the time were later discovered to be close friends with Craig and Rodney Minogue. Again, that's all alleged. It is denied by the Minogue brothers. There was a witness, Laura, not her real name, who says she was actually with McConville and Camilleri on one occasion when they drove to Glenroy looking for Pru. During the drive, Camilleri and McConville mentioned they were looking for a girl that had to be bumped, and if they didn't get rid of her, they were fucked. Laura also says that she saw Pru at McConville's house tied up and asking for her mum. The day she disappeared. Now, all of that is alleged. It can't be proven. And for that reason, it was never pressed by the prosecution in court. There is a difference between knowing something or believing something happened and being able to prove it to the required standard in a courtroom.
另一个转折是，珍妮·伯德声称在普鲁失踪前一周，她在街上看到了罗德尼·米诺格。不仅如此，她说普鲁当时男友的一些家人后来被发现与克雷格和罗德尼·米诺格是好朋友。同样，这些都是指控。米诺格兄弟对此予以否认。有一位证人劳拉（化名）说，有一次她确实和麦康维尔及卡米莱里在一起，当时他们开车去格伦罗伊寻找普鲁。开车期间，卡米莱里和麦康维尔提到他们正在寻找一个必须被“干掉”的女孩，如果他们不除掉她，他们就死定了。劳拉还说，她看到普鲁在麦康维尔家被绑着，哭着找妈妈。就在她失踪的那天。现在，所有这些都是指控。无法证明。因此，检方从未在法庭上提出这些证据。知道某事或相信某事发生，与能够在法庭上达到要求的标准来证明它，是有区别的。
There are a lot of probables and possibles and maybes surrounding Pru's case. Unfortunately, the full truth will most likely never be known. Mark McConville died in jail in 2003. He was there for an unrelated charge. So he was dead before his name was ever linked to Pru's case. Stan Taylor and Craig Minogue both strongly deny ever making a threat against Pru and obviously deny having anything to do with her death. Camilleri is sticking to his story, insisting he acted alone. An accident. He just wanted to question Pru about her father's whereabouts. The judge said he didn't believe his story and instructed Camilleri that it might be time to exercise his conscience. But he never did. To this day, Camilleri has never even said where he left Pru's body. He has given a couple of different stories. One that he placed her inside a fridge at Frankston Tip and another that he buried her in Bushland. Searches of those areas revealed no trace of Pru.
普鲁的案件周围有很多可能性、概率和不确定性。不幸的是，全部真相很可能永远不会为人所知。马克·麦康维尔于2003年在狱中去世。他当时是因为一项无关的指控入狱。所以他在名字与普鲁案件联系起来之前就已经死了。斯坦·泰勒和克雷格·米诺格都强烈否认曾对普鲁发出过威胁，显然也否认与她的死有任何关系。卡米莱里坚持他的故事，坚称他是单独行动。一个意外。他只是想问普鲁关于她父亲下落的问题。法官说他不相信他的故事，并指示卡米莱里现在可能是行使良心的时候了。但他从未这样做。直到今天，卡米莱里甚至从未说过他把普鲁的尸体留在了哪里。他给出了几个不同的故事。一个是他把她放在了弗兰克斯顿垃圾场的冰箱里，另一个是他把她埋在了丛林里。对这些区域的搜查没有发现普鲁的任何踪迹。
Jenny Bird read a victim impact statement at the sentencing hearing pleading with Camilleri to tell her where Pru's body was so she could be given a proper burial. But he refused. Camilleri was sentenced to 28 years in jail for Pru Bird's murder, which of course is totally irrelevant because he was already serving a life sentence without the possibility of parole. During sentencing, the judge conceded many of the facts of the case were unclear, as Camilleri's version was unreliable. However, the judge was satisfied. Camilleri abducted and murdered Pru with the help of two other men. Camilleri is unreliable. Stan Taylor has a terminal illness and a severe hatred of authority. Mark McConville is dead. Craig Minogue is due for parole in a couple of months and strongly denies any involvement in Pru Bird's case. Rodney Minogue was questioned but there was no evidence on him and he also strongly denies any involvement.
珍妮·伯德在量刑听证会上宣读了一份受害者影响陈述，恳求卡米莱里告诉她普鲁的尸体在哪里，以便她能得到妥善安葬。但他拒绝了。卡米莱里因谋杀普鲁·伯德被判处28年监禁，当然这完全无关紧要，因为他已经在服终身监禁且不得假释。在量刑期间，法官承认案件的许多事实不清楚，因为卡米莱里的版本不可靠。然而，法官确信卡米莱里在另外两名男子的帮助下绑架并谋杀了普鲁。卡米莱里不可靠。斯坦·泰勒患有绝症，对权威有严重的仇恨。马克·麦康维尔已经死了。克雷格·米诺格几个月后将获得假释，并强烈否认与普鲁·伯德的案件有任何牵连。罗德尼·米诺格受到了质询，但没有证据指向他，他也强烈否认有任何参与。
But Paul Hetzel has no doubt his cooperation with police was the cause of Pru's death, although there is not enough evidence to prove it in court. To this day the case remains open and efforts are ongoing to try and locate Pru's body. Pru Bird's murder, which of course is totally irrelevant because he was already serving a life sentence without the possibility of parole. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但保罗·赫策尔毫不怀疑他与警方的合作是导致普鲁死亡的原因，尽管没有足够的证据在法庭上证明这一点。直到今天，案件仍然悬而未决，寻找普鲁尸体的努力仍在继续。普鲁·伯德的谋杀案，当然这完全无关紧要，因为他已经在服终身监禁且不得假释。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。